hi Barry or should I say the flash dr.
wells is the man in yellow everything
he's been doing helping me it was all
alive you're not gonna get away with it
he's got talking wells killed my mom
it's don't think it's a coincidence that
this gorilla shows up at the very same
time we're looking for wells
if I hadn't seen Jurassic Park I
wouldn't be nearly as frightened right
now father probably I mean mid-wales
wells ordered Grodd to come after us to
distract this
it
hey youtubers is charlie so new trailer
for next week's episode Grodd lives full
of all kinds of gorilla amazingness so
this is gonna be breakdown so just to go
in chronological order iris West finds
out who Barry Allen is and everyone was
asking about the spark does that mean
the iris have some sort of Speed Force
connection herself in the past iris West
and other flash family members have
gotten speed force powers but I don't
know if they're gonna go there that soon
on the show they have said that they
might introduce Wally West in season 2
they didn't say how they're gonna do
that they just said it might happen I do
think at some point we will see a female
speedster even if it's only temporary if
you ever read any of Geoff Johns run
towards the end of it towards the end of
the Wally West run that he was working
on before flashpoint his wife Linda Park
who we've seen on the flash already and
his two children gain Speed Force
abilities but that was only temporary
his comic booky is the flashes I think
the most ridiculous thing that will see
before the end of the season is a
talking gorilla it looks like we'll
spend more time in the reverse flash to
the secret volcano lair I wonder if it's
only accessible via that ladder they're
like it's like some secret control room
here's Barry sitting on the treadmill I
do kind of wonder if they'll go cosmic
treadmill round there's just there's so
many iconic images of the flash fighting
the reverse flash while running on the
treadmill that I feel like if they're
gonna go like super comic booky that
would be something you'd want to include
before the end of the season so here in
this scene look at that little vial that
Wells is working on I made a joke on
Twitter that you know what if Wells were
to steal the omega that's probably not
the omega from arrow that's point out
the virus it's probably a piece of tech
based on farooq's powers you know how he
was able to steal the Flash's powers
earlier this season the reverse flash is
going to need to steal Barry Allen's
Speed Force if he's going to get back
home so it's more likely that this has
something to do with that plot line
don't be surprised if Eddie Thawne and
eel Barth on spend the rest of the
season together team flash might not be
able to rescue him till the finale and
for those asking i know everyone asks
why the reverse flashes eyes glow red
it's really just a function of how his
body utilizes the Speed Force he knows a
lot more about the science of the Speed
Force how it works how to use it to his
benefit then Barry does in the comics
he's able to use the negative Speed
Force to do all kinds of crazy things
like he can age and D age himself like
he can actually literally change the age
of his bow
body the hollywood television reason why
his eyes glow red is so you know that
he's the villain if you're like a little
kid and you have trouble remembering who
the bad person is that's a very comic
booky device make the villain look
scarier than the hero as Barry says
wells 6 Grodd on them to distract him
from whatever Wells is going to be doing
presumably finishing his text so that he
can steal Barry's powers I like the fact
that Grodd called Wells father as if
it's like some sort of Frankenstein or
island of dr. Moreau type thing I think
it would be closer to island of dr.
Moreau because Grodd wasn't dead to
begin with it wasn't like he brought
something to life the interesting thing
to know that you know even though Grodd
in the comics is a villain he's not like
best friends with the reverse flash
villains more ofter than not just dis
form temporary alliances the frenemy of
my enemy is my friend you guys can let
me know what you think of like the full
model of Grodd I I think he looks
amazing for a TV budget the good thing
the really good thing about this is that
as we get on in years it gets cheaper
and cheaper to do digital effects like
this it's just easier and easier for
them to do it so by the time we get to
like flash season 5 it'll be way cheaper
for them to use Grodd so if you ever
wondered if we're going to get to
gorilla City or anything crazy like that
or so lavar think season 3 4 5 it just
gets way easier way cheaper for them to
do it and for those asking the same
actor that's voicing Grodd is also
voicing Drax the destroyer in the
guardians of the galaxy cartoon how cool
is that here's a much better close up
shot of Grodd that looks amazing and
then boom a nice twist on that that
rocky ending they did in the flash vs
arrow two-part episode the flashing
Grodd running straight at each other
just a couple other notes from last
week's episode 2 there was supposed to
be a caitlin snow flashback but danielle
panabaker said that it might have been
cut from the final edit sometimes that
will happen like those shoot scenes and
the episode will run long so they ought
to just cut stuff so we might see a lot
of caitlin snow edits on the DVD release
what I'm hoping is is that a lot of
times they end up cutting scenes like
that they'll just release them as clips
online the CW is really good about
posting online clips way way back you
used to have to wait for the DVD release
for stuff like that so many many thanks
to the people at the CW for those asking
about Supergirl to I have some Supergirl
news it's good and bad so the good news
is is that the people at CBS really love
the pilot so dollars to donuts we will
get Supergirl
bad news is is that they might hold it
and use it as a summer series in 2016 so
they wouldn't start airing episodes till
next summer not this summer so worst
case scenario we'll just have to wait
like a year to see Supergirl because
they finish the pilot what I'm really
hoping though is that they'll air to
comic-con but they haven't confirmed
anything comic-con is at the beginning
of July so they might say something then
but if it's so far out they might not
spend a whole lot of energy promoting
Supergirl they might wait till next
summer to start promoting it and
remember it's CBS it's not CW so they
might be able to use the CW shows to
promote a little bit because CBS and CW
are owned by the same company it
technically it's all Warner Brothers
television but don't expect a lot of
Supergirl people to cross over to the CW
shows and that includes the spin-off
show I'm going to be posting this week's
arrow flash Q&A next they released the
first image of Stephen Amell as Casey
Jones and Ninja Turtles too so I'll talk
about that in that video too he's gonna
be slicing some people up with a hockey
stick in in slightly related news
hopefully you guys have had a chance to
see Avengers age of Ultron two or three
times already you can click here for my
spoilery breakdown if you've already
seen it or if you just want spoilers and
you can click here to learn all about
grodd's origin story in the comics thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you